tax the rich is a very popular sentiment
it's also now a fashion statement i
guess which we which we've all seen
so when president biden looks into the
microphone and says pay your fair share
what does that mean
it means that if you're one of the 55
corporations that literally paid
absolutely nothing in federal income
taxes in 2020
and in fact received 3.5 billion dollars
in tax refunds or rebates
or tax refunds i should say uh maybe you
should uh pay your fair share but here's
the thing if the tax code is written in
a way
where corporations can legally take
advantage of loopholes and incredibly
low effective corporate tax rates
they're going to do it right so it's one
thing to say pay your fair share it's
another thing to actually write
a tax code that is a little more
equitable and ensures that everyone is
in fact paying their fair share ben
what's pay your fair share mean i mean
the the obvious answer would be a flat
tax but the the longer answer is that
the united states has one of the most
progressive income tax systems on planet
earth uh most of these systems in for
example northern europe are far less
progressive the the top tax rate kicks
in a lot lower on the income scale
because you have to pay for the
large-scale social services uh the the
people who are at the top of the income
back in the united states the top
quintile essentially pays all nut taxes
in the united states not some not most
all and the reason for that is because
there are tax transfers and the transfer
of payments that are inherent in public
services do not accrue to the people at
the top of the tax bracket they accrue
to everybody else who's receiving that
sort of funding when we talk about you
know higher taxes on corporations we do
not have one of the world's lowest
corporate tax rates we are somewhere in
the middle in looking at the oecd
countries where we're certainly not the
lowest on the totem pole in terms of our
corporate tax rate in fact you know
right-wing sources like the heritage
foundation will say that it is much
friendlier to do business in places like
denmark or sweden in many cases than it
is to business in the united states tax
rate's pretty high in denmark and sweden
the personal income tax rate is very
high in denmark and sweden the corporate
tax rate is
basically near or on par with that of
the united states if we were to raise
our corporate tax rate the way that
president biden is talking about we'd
actually have a higher corporate tax
rate than china currently does uh the
the notion that corporations ought to be
paying tax at all in my view is mistaken
given the fact that the income is
immediately either reinvested in the
company or passed on to people who
immediately pay all of that tax by the
time the by the time you actually
receive your income in this country the
income has been taxed about seven
different ways right you're getting
taxed through the corporation then it's
passed on to your salary which is taxed
if you invest in the stock market and
then you sell your stock that is taxed
as capital gains tax when you die the
government taxes that as well so how
many times can you tax the same dollar
before people begin to disinvest
[Applause]
let me um
i'd like to respond to that though okay
go ahead
go ahead to argue that the uh corporate
tax rates in the united states are too
high or that you know i mean first off
let me just
touch on the comparison you gave
regarding uh taxes progressive taxes uh
in european countries versus the united
states i mean yes the taxes might be
higher in those european countries but
what do people living in those countries
get in return they get incredible child
care i mean listen uh the average
american family two-income household
spends a whopping 22 percent
of their household income on child care
alone right so
when you're talking about european
countries that offer quality child care
that by the way that opens up the
opportunity for people to go to work
something that we should maybe think
about as we're dealing with this labor
shortage 64 000 women left the job force
in april alone not because they want to
but because they can't afford child care
everything in this country is privatized
everything has a for-profit model and
there's consequences that come along
with that including for the business
community that might want you know a
more robust social safety net uh program
or social safety net to ensure that
people
feel comfortable enough to go to work
but we don't have that here so yes
people might pay more in taxes including
those lower on the income scale but what
they get in return is far greater than
what people in this country have been
getting
the united states has spent since the
beginning of the war on poverty some 22
trillion dollars in the war on poverty
we spend an awful lot on social services
in this country on a per capita level in
fact it is very much on par with what
the european countries spend it's just
not spent particularly well when it
comes to things like child care a very
young elizabeth warren before she became
senator elizabeth warren specifically
wrote about universal child care and she
said that it actually was contributing
to what she called the two income track
in a book that she wrote in the early
2000s and what you talked about is the
fact that there are a lot of women who
for example may not want to work and
what you're actually doing is
incentivizing people to have to go to
work because you're now providing child
care as opposed to providing a
competitive advantage to for example
families where one parent is working i
agree with you by the way that you know
child care is a very difficult issue i
also agree that this is why we used to
have for example family structures that
were conducive to allowing people to
help out we had we there are many
businesses that do provide for some form
of child care we certainly have many
businesses that provide for some form of
maternity or paternity leave
the the european countries which
obviously have been used as a model by
by a lot of folks on the left between
1970 and 1993 they experienced
exorbitantly low
rates of growth and the reason for that
was because they radically overburdened
their social safety net systems it
created enormous social problems it
created enormous immigration problems
they had to scale a lot of those back
and why
why would it create immigration problems
it created immigration problems because
a lot of people were coming specifically
for the benefits yeah okay well yes that
would be that would be to my point which
is it creates more problems very often
than it is i mean but i mean
sure i guess that's yes if i put a free
donut sign in my shop people will come
for this no but if you have if you have
a robust if you have a society that
actually takes care of its workers right
if you have a society that makes your
life a lot easier people are going to
want to immigra that's part of the
reason why
you know people wanted to come here
people are going to want to live in
countries that have both economic
opportunities the fastest immigration
they're the best
programs that again just make your i
mean we talk about freedom if you look
at the world freedom index okay we like
to think of the united states as the
freest country we're not the freest
country you look at that list we're like
pretty low down compared to a lot of
these nordic countries denmark is
top of that list so look denmark has a
mixed economy when we have these debates
about ooh socialism versus capitalism i
think that those debates are a little
ridiculous because every country is a
well not every country but most
countries are mixed economies right the
united states rights economy
now
the issue with the united states is
there used to be a time when public
universities were free right you didn't
have to dig yourself into a massive hole
to get an education there was a time in
this country where there was universal
child care that was
cut down to the point where it's like no
longer in existence unless you're
desperate and have like no money and
need to take advantage of some programs
that are available in some states but my
point is like
we have an issue here where on one hand
you know we're experiencing a labor
shortage we want people to go back to
work on the other hand people literally
can't afford the child care necessary in
order to put their kids in a daycare put
their kids in child care and be able to
go to work without their entire pace
the biden bill removes many work
requirements for many of the payments
that are being made to people and it's
incentivizing people not to go to back
to work is why we have 10 million open
jobs in the united states and people not
coming back that's not that is not what
that bill does in fact
that's not what that means are you
talking about the right uh 3.5 trillion
dollars i'm talking about the 3.5
trillion 3.5 trillion dollar
reconciliation tax credit offers
universal pre-k which opens up the
opportunity for mothers to go to work if
they want to go to work the 3.5 trillion
dollar bill by the way has all sorts of
subsidies for corporations which i don't
really understand why the business
community isn't salivating over that
because rather than just going full
force with public programs which i think
would be the right way to go it's
offering all sorts of subsidies
in these you know public-private
partnerships now the physical
infrastructure bill has a lot more
corporate giveaways which is why the you
know business community absolutely loves
it offers the chance to privatize public
infrastructure which is why the business
community absolutely loves it uh but at
the end of the day if we don't create a
society where americans can actually
have families and go to work then we're
going to be in a lot of trouble so go
back to your immigration point you made
a mention a moment ago of people
immigrating to the country for the
benefits that's just abjectly untrue the
fact is that the united states is great
immigration growth throughout the
beginning of the republic all the way up
through about 1930 was entirely driven
by people who were leaving places that
in many cases had broader benefits
places like germany to come to the
united states where there was no social
safety net the fact is that the vast
majority of people who used to leave and
come to the united states were coming
specifically to build life knowing that
they really didn't have a lot of social
safety net now that's not an argument
that there shouldn't be some state and
local possibility for social safety net
but the notion that the way that you
build a successful country that is a
world power and is capable of not only
making sure that the citizens are taken
care of but essentially making sure that
the entire western world is taken care
of which we did throughout the cold war
the idea that you do that simply by
raising the number of social security
payments that you're making to people or
benefit payments that you're making to
people this is the way that you build
that sort of economy is just not borne
out by impeachment we've had a real
far-ranging conversation